>> Sean: AN OUTRAGEOUS
DECISION OUT OF THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT TODAY BY A 5-4
COURT.
THEY RULED THAT EFFORTS TO END
THE UNILATERAL PROGRAM THAT GAVE
LEGAL PROTECTIONS TO IMMIGRANTS
BROUGHT TO THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY
AS CHILDREN AND JUST LIKE IN THE
CASE OF OBAMACARE, IT WAS
CHIEF JUSTICE JOHN ROBERTS
JOINING THE FOUR LIBERALS ON THE
COURT TO MAKE A HIGHLY TECHNICAL
RIDICULOUS ARGUMENT THAT
BENEFITED THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
NOW EVEN BARACK OBAMA HIMSELF
RECOGNIZED HE CAN DO THIS BY THE
EXECUTIVE BUT DID IT ANYWAY
BEFORE ROLLING OUT DACA IN 2012,
OBAMA SAID HE NEEDED AN ACT OF
CONGRESS TO HELP THE SO-CALLED
DREAMERS.
WATCH THIS CLIP OF HIM
ADDRESSING IMMIGRATION ACTIVISTS
IN 2011.
>> I KNOW SOME PEOPLE WANT ME TO
BYPASS CONGRESS AND CHANGE THE
LAWS ON MY OWN.
THE IDEA OF DOING THINGS ON MY
OWN IS VERY TEMPTING.
I PROMISE YOU, NOT JUST ON
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
BUT THAT IS NOT HOW OUR SYSTEM
WORKS.
THAT IS NOT HOW OUR DEMOCRACY
FUNCTIONS.
>> Sean: DEMOCRATIC PUBLIC
HERE WITH THE REACTION, ACTING
DH SECRETARY CHAO 12.
HE IS ADMITTING HE DIDN’T HAVE
THE POWER TO DO IT AND HE DID IT
ANYWAY.
JOHN ROBERTS DID THIS WITH
HEALTH CARE.
MAY BE ONCE A DIFFERENT JOB
TITLE IN HIS LIFE BECAUSE
CERTAINLY NOT FOLLOWING THE LAW
BY ANY REASONABLE ANALYSIS THAT
I SEE.
>> WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT
THE DACA PROGRAM IS UNLAWFUL.
SAID THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
RESCIND IT.
THEY SIMPLY DIDN’T LIKE THE WAY
THEY WERE DOING AND I THINK THAT
IS TROUBLING TO ME BECAUSE WHAT
WE SAW UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, A CLIP THAT YOU
JUST PLAYED AS THEY MADE THIS
PROGRAM OUT OF THIN AIR, THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS THOUGHT LONG
ABOUT THIS, DECIDED TO WIND THIS
UNLAWFUL PROGRAM DOWN OVER A
SERIES OF SIX MONTHS AND AGAIN,
WHAT WE HAVE IS A SUPREME COURT
SAYING THAT’S NOT GOOD ENOUGH,
YOU NEED TO GO BACK AT IT AND
RELOOK AT THAT AND THAT IS VERY
TROUBLING TO ME.
>> Sean: AND HE ADMITTED THAT
HE DIDN’T DO IT, BUT HE DID IT
ANYWAY.
WAS A CONSTITUTIONAL?
BECAUSE I DON’T BELIEVE IT WAS.
>> THAT’S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
WE HAVE ONE ADMINISTRATION
MAKING A PROGRAM, A SECOND
ADMINISTRATION TAKING A LOOK AT
HOW DO WE WIND DOWN AND UNLAWFUL
PROGRAM.
WHAT THEY DID IS CREATE A NEW
LAW, A NEW PROGRAM THE DEFERRED
ACTION PROGRAM OUT OF THIN AIR.
WE HAVE BEEN BEGGING CONGRESS TO
ADDRESS THE DACA RECIPIENTS,
THEY HAVE DECIDED NOT TO DO THIS
TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN A CLEAR
AROUND US AND WANTS A LEGAL
SOLUTION AND NOT A POLITICAL
SOLUTION TO THIS ISSUE.
VERY DISAPPOINTED IN THE
DECISION TODAY, BUT WILL KEEP AT